[Music]
as protests over the police killing of
andrew brown jr continue
his family members were allowed to watch
a snippet of police body camera video
showing brown being shot repeatedly they
were outraged by what they saw
my dad got executed just by trying to
save his own life
you know he was not in no the officers
was not in no harm
of him at all it's just messed up how
this happened man
brown was killed on april 21st in
elizabeth city north carolina by
police serving a drug-related arrest
warrant
the killing sparked days of protests his
relatives
and their attorneys say brown posed no
threat
to officers as he tried to leave the
scene in his vehicle
andrew had his hands on his steering
wheel he was not reaching for anything
he wasn't touching anything he wasn't
throwing anything around he had his
hands
firmly on the steering wheel they run up
to his vehicle shooting
seven deputies have been placed on leave
brown's family and protesters
demand authorities release the full body
camera videos
from several officers why couldn't the
family see all the video
the truth will come out the video
will be seen by the public and we will
get
justice for andrew brown jr
the biden administration is under
political pressure to make good on the
president's pledges to pursue police
reform
and end racial disparities it announced
on monday
that it would conduct a sweeping
investigation of the police department
and local government in louisville
kentucky
following the police shooting of brianna
taylor
a black woman in her home there last
year
it will determine whether lmpd engages
in unconstitutional stops
searches and seizures as well as whether
the department unlawfully executes
search warrants on private homes
it will also assess whether lmpd engages
in discriminatory conduct on the basis
of race
in the days since former minneapolis
police officer
derek chovan was convicted of murdering
george floyd 11 months ago police
around the u.s have shot and killed at
least
half a dozen people leading to more
nationwide cries for racial justice
and reform rob reynolds al jazeera